Alice: 火小一点
Alice: Lower the flame a bit.
Tasha: 火已经很小了
Tasha: The flame is already low.
Alice: 你锅里是不是有油
Alice: Do you have oil in the pot?
Alice: 哎不对
Alice: Oh no.
Alice: 有水
Alice: There's water.
Tasha: 没有我已经把水抽干了
Tasha: No, I've already dried the water out.
Lucia: 这锅昨天是不是用过呀
Lucia: Was this pot used yesterday?
Tasha: 我靠这锅怎么这么倒
Tasha: Damn, why is this pot so...
Tasha: 倒热怎么这么快
Tasha: It heats up so fast.
Alice: 它比较薄
Alice: It's pretty thin.
Tasha: 拿一个那个小小小碟子来呗
Tasha: Can you get a small, small, small plate?
Tasha: 放这些饼
Tasha: To put these pancakes on.
Alice: 好
Alice: Sure.
Alice: 露西亚你就不用帮我热了吧
Alice: Lucia, you don't need to heat it up for me.
Alice: 倒直接倒就行了
Alice: Just pour it directly.
Alice: 给你
Alice: Here you go.
Alice: 笑死了这个这个
Alice: This is hilarious.
Alice: 手机拍的好整齐你看
Alice: The phones are lined up so neatly, look.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 像开会一样
Alice: It's like a meeting.
Tasha: 开会上交手机
Tasha: Collecting phones for the meeting.
Lucia: 手机开会
Lucia: Phone meeting.
Tasha: 也不知道熟了没
Tasha: I wonder if it's cooked.
Tasha: 外面都糊了
Tasha: It's burnt outside.
Alice: 没
Alice: No.
Alice: 这太短了时间
Alice: It's too short a time.
Tasha: 那只能用小火煎了
Tasha: Then we can only use low heat to fry it.
Tasha: 看看不清了都
Tasha: Look, it's all blurred.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Alice: 你看这里面还爆浆呢
Alice: Look, it's oozing inside.
Alice: 当然没熟
Alice: Of course it's not cooked.
Lucia: 你昨天没有开牛奶吗
Lucia: Didn't you open the milk yesterday?
Lucia: 应该开过一瓶吧
Lucia: You should have opened a bottle.
Alice: 看里面都不熟呢
Alice: Look, it's not cooked inside.
Tasha: 外面都已经这么黑了
Tasha: It's already so burnt outside.
Alice: 油一点点大哈
Alice: The oil is a bit too much.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 太厚了没关系没关系
Alice: It's too thick, it's okay, it's okay.
Alice: 把那个外面面的那个丢掉就行
Alice: Just throw away the outer layer.
Tasha: OK第一个饼现给杨老板吃
Tasha: OK, the first pancake goes to Jake.
Tasha: 我这个锅怎么回事
Tasha: What's wrong with this pan?
Tasha: 太可怕了
Tasha: It's terrible.
Alice: 你要不给弄开吧好
Alice: If you can't, just open it.
Alice: 勉强
Alice: Barely.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 我怎么每次开门都会掉点东西下来啊
Lucia: Why do I always drop something when I open the door?
Alice: 小一点
Alice: Smaller.
Tasha: 没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 我来把这个也也也剪开
Tasha: I'll cut this open too.
Lucia: 我可以用一下另一个灶吗
Lucia: Can I use the other stove?
Tasha: 要要用微波炉
Tasha: You want to use the microwave.
Tasha: 呃呃好吧
Tasha: Uh, okay.
Jake:哎呀卧槽
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 这个也可以了
Tasha: This one is fine too.
Lucia: 微波炉打吗
Lucia: Should we microwave it?
Lucia: 微波炉打不知道能不能打的透
Lucia: Not sure if the microwave can heat it through.
Lucia: 而且没事就放在这吧
Lucia: Anyway, just leave it here.
Lucia: 然后大家再倒出来就好
Lucia: Then everyone can pour it out later.
Tasha: 啊这个锅太可怕了
Tasha: Ah, this pot is scary.
Alice: 哎呦好拍掉点东西
Alice: Oh no, something fell.
Lucia: 哎这个灶台
Lucia: Oh, this stove.
Alice: 露西亚你准备的是几个人的牛奶
Alice: Lucia, how many people are you making milk for?
Lucia: 呃没事我们可以随便倒哈哈
Lucia: Uh, it's fine, we can pour it as we like, haha.
Alice: 啊因为我想喝凉的
Alice: Ah, because I want to drink it cold.
Lucia: 你想喝凉的
Lucia: You want it cold?
Lucia: 呃有还有
Lucia: Uh, we still have more.
Alice: 啊对
Alice: Ah, right.
Alice: 就是不用算我的量就可以了
Alice: So, don't count mine.
Lucia: 没事那就如果多了的话
Lucia: No problem, if there's too much,
Lucia: 大家一会多喝一点就好了哈哈
Lucia: everyone can drink a bit more later, haha.
Alice: 啊好
Alice: Ah, okay.
Alice: 可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 就是那个那个已经打开的我也没倒完
Lucia: The one that's already open, I haven't finished pouring.
Lucia: 然后假如你不够喝
Lucia: And if you don't have enough,
Lucia: 你也可以打开那个新的
Lucia: you can open the new one.
Alice: 啊不用谢谢
Alice: Ah, no need, thanks.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: No worries, no worries.
Tasha: 喔
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Oh, be careful.
Alice: 这个我自己倒吧
Alice: I'll pour this myself.
Lucia: 啊好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 然后我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Lucia: 我们牛奶应该是要用杯子
Lucia: We should use cups for the milk.
Lucia: 我把剩下这几杯子都洗了
Lucia: I'll wash the rest of these cups.
Alice: 我直接用碗了
Alice: I'll just use a bowl.
Lucia: 也可以哈哈
Lucia: That works too, haha.
Lucia: 这个任君选择
Lucia: Whatever you prefer.
Alice: 呵呵呵呵
Lucia: 23234 那我们剩下有 4个
Lucia: 23234, so we have 4 left.
Lucia: 人都
Lucia: Everyone...
Alice: 外国人一点震撼
Alice: Foreigners are a bit shocked.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 雨轩你要单喝纯牛奶吗
Lucia: Yuxuan, do you want to drink plain milk?
Alice: 这眼镜有点松
Alice: These glasses are a bit loose.
Lucia: 还是你还喝你刚才的咖啡哦
Lucia: Or do you want your coffee from earlier?
Katrina:  不用我就喝我自己这个就行
Katrina: No need, I'll just drink this one.
Lucia: 好的好的
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 那我们就三个杯子哎
Lucia: So we only need three cups then.
Lucia: 那牛奶可能稍微有点多
Lucia: The milk might be a bit too much.
Alice: 没事喝不完可以给我
Alice: No worries, if you can't finish, give it to me.
Lucia: 啊可以哈哈你可以等他凉了再喝
Lucia: Sure, haha, you can wait until it cools down to drink.
Lucia: 或者我们多喝一点
Lucia: Or we can drink a bit more.
Alice: 没事没事
Alice: No worries, no worries.
Alice: 我只是比较喜欢喝凉的
Alice: I just prefer drinking it cool.
Lucia: 我和薇薇多喝一点
Lucia: Tasha and I will drink a bit more.
Lucia: 因为那个靖康他好像也要喝咖啡
Lucia: Because Jingkang seems to want coffee too.
Tasha: OK第二次做的是薄饼
Tasha: Okay, the second time we made pancakes.
Alice: 你你那个离他远一点
Alice: Hey, move a bit farther from it.
Alice: 因为怕熏到你的眼镜
Alice: Because I'm afraid it might smoke up your glasses.
Tasha: 颠勺颠勺
Tasha: Flip the pan, flip the pan.
Alice: 哎哎小心点小心点啊
Alice: Hey, be careful, be careful.
Tasha: 我靠太可怕了
Tasha: Oh my god, it's so scary.
Lucia: 哦我在把我手机的
Lucia: Oh, I'm turning on my phone's...
Lucia: 铃声打开
Lucia: ...ringer.
Lucia: 要不然一会万一外卖到了的话
Lucia: Otherwise, if the delivery arrives...
Lucia: 我听不见
Lucia: ...I won't hear it.
Tasha: 熟了吗熟了好像
Tasha: Is it done? It seems like it is.
Alice: 哎小心点怎么了
Alice: Hey, be careful, what's going on?
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What's going on?
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Alice: 这给它搁哪呢
Alice: Where should we put this?
Alice: 咋了我看看
Alice: What's up, let me see.
Tasha: 锅溅油了
Tasha: Oil got into the pan.
Tasha: 这真是一个脾气不好的锅
Tasha: This is really a bad-tempered pan.
Alice: 可以等油没那么热的时候就放进去
Alice: You can put it in when the oil is not that hot.
Tasha: 我关小火了他还是崩了
Tasha: I turned down the heat, but it's still splattering.
Alice: 油太热的那啥嗯
Alice: The oil is too hot, hmm.
Alice: 因为我们那个面粉里有含水吗
Alice: Because our flour contains water, right?
Tasha: 含
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 时间太久给他烧开了
Lucia: It boiled because it took too long.
Alice: 筷子竟然不是一样长的
Alice: The chopsticks aren't the same length.
Alice: 这就顺眼了
Alice: This looks better now.
Alice: 露西亚你把它拿起来一下
Alice: Lucia, can you lift it up for a moment?
Alice: 因为这个桌布应该不耐高温
Alice: Because this tablecloth isn't heat-resistant.
Lucia: 把这个稍微往中间放一点
Lucia: Let's move this a bit more to the center.
Lucia: 啊不过一会中间还要放蛋饼
Lucia: Oh, but we need to add the egg pancake in the middle for a bit.
Lucia: 也不需要那么中间放一会吧
Lucia: It doesn't need to be in the middle for too long, right?
Lucia: 然后把这边上稍微挪一下
Lucia: Then move this side a little bit.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 这是你的咖啡吗
Lucia: Is this your coffee?
Alice: 我已经倒进去了
Alice: I already poured it.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 那这个应该是刚才给靖康拿出来的
Lucia: Then this one must be the one we took out for Jingkang earlier.
Lucia: 给他放回去
Lucia: Let's put it back for him.
Lucia: 他一会下来了再拿吧
Lucia: He can get it later when he comes down.
Lucia: 要不然东桌上东西太多了
Lucia: Otherwise, there'll be too much stuff on the table.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 很棒
Alice: Great.
Tasha: 已经与他和平相处了
Tasha: I've already made peace with him.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 我说已经与他和平相处了
Tasha: I said I've already made peace with him.
Alice: 那我帮你把这个洗了吧
Alice: Then let me help you wash this.
Alice: 给你做收尾工作
Alice: I'll finish up for you.
Alice: 先搁哪呢
Alice: Where should I put it first?
Alice: 这也太难洗了
Alice: This is so hard to wash.
Katrina:  好像幼儿园舞蹈
Katrina: Looks like a kindergarten dance.
Katrina:  好啊哈哈
Katrina: Haha, yeah.
Lucia: 对这个这个音乐比较比较
Lucia: Yeah, this music is quite...
Katrina:  比较可爱
Katrina: Quite cute.
Katrina:  啊他们有3个
Katrina: Ah, they have three.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 啊不用接听
Tasha: No need to answer.
Lucia: 个音乐真的好幼儿园
Lucia: This music is really like kindergarten.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  但只有这种就大家都能都听过的音乐
Katrina: But only this kind of music that everyone has heard.
Katrina:  才能
Katrina: Can...
Lucia: 倒了吗倒出来了
Lucia: Is it poured out? Is it out?
Alice: 关火了吗
Alice: Did you turn off the heat?
Tasha: 没呢
Alice: 翻面了吧该
Alice: Should flip it over now.
Tasha: 嗯我看一下
Tasha: Hmm, let me check.
Lucia: 哎比较合适是的
Lucia: Yeah, that's more appropriate.
Katrina:  怎么没有起舞了又
Katrina: Why aren't they dancing again?
Alice: 变松我紧一下
Lucia: 后面这段的音乐好像
Lucia: The music at the end seems...
Katrina:  但是他起舞不多
Katrina: But they don't dance much.
Alice: 熟了吧
Alice: Is it done?
Tasha: 熟了
Tasha: It's done.
Alice:吃吧
Alice: Let's eat.
Lucia: 我我投这个一票
Lucia: I vote for this one.
Lucia: 我觉得这个鼓点强一些
Lucia: I think this beat is stronger.
Katrina:  嗯嗯但这这个怕他们有点
Katrina: Yeah, but I'm worried they might have too many moves.
Katrina:  动作还挺多
Katrina: There are quite a lot of actions.
Lucia: 或者可以把就是难度高一点的动作
Lucia: Or we can just cut out the more difficult moves.
Lucia: 给他删掉
Lucia: Remove them.
Katrina:  改了
Katrina: Change it.
Lucia: 对重新编一下
Lucia: Yeah, re-choreograph it.
Lucia: 我们可以从这段开始
Lucia: We can start from this part.
Lucia: 我觉得这对
Lucia: I think this is good.
Lucia: 然后这个就是前面出现过的那一部分
Lucia: And then this is the part that appeared earlier.
Lucia: 就是可以省略掉一些
Lucia: We can skip some of it.
Lucia: 就是比较强那个什么的
Lucia: The stronger part or whatever.
Tasha: 吃吃吃
Tasha: Eat, eat, eat.
Tasha: 早饭了
Tasha: It's breakfast time.
Alice: 我拿个充电宝
Alice: I'll get a power bank.
Alice: 我怕这个没电
Alice: I’m afraid this might run out of battery.
Alice: 充电宝在哪里嘞
Alice: Where's the power bank?
Tasha: 人怎么不齐
Tasha: Why is everyone not here?
Alice: 进去不太好吧
Alice: Is it okay to go in?
Tasha: 要不要喊他一起吃
Tasha: Should we call him to eat together?
Alice: 他好像刚好像看他出去了还是怎样
Alice: It seemed like he just went out or something.
Tasha: 哦那还要喊他吗
Tasha: Oh, should we still call him?
Lucia: 突然breaking了起来哈哈
Lucia: Suddenly started breaking, haha.
Katrina:  对要不就前面1分半看看
Katrina: Yeah, maybe just watch the first 1.5 minutes.
Alice: 差不多关了
Alice: Almost done.
Katrina:  1分多够拍
Katrina: A bit more than a minute is enough to shoot.
Katrina:  哈哈够够呛
Katrina: Haha, it's quite tough.
Alice:能掉吗
Alice: Can it fall off?
Alice: 留着吧
Alice: Just leave it.
Tasha: 谁用碗喝咖啡吗
Tasha: Who uses a bowl to drink coffee?
Alice:我
Alice: Me.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Katrina:  到底在哪跳啊
Katrina: Where exactly are we dancing?
Katrina:  外面还是二楼啊
Katrina: Outside or on the second floor?
Lucia: 可能是外面吧
Lucia: Maybe outside.
Lucia: 但是其我在想是外面没有什么舞台
Lucia: But I was thinking there's no stage outside.
Katrina:  外面是石子哎
Katrina: It's gravel outside.
Lucia: 然后二楼又不够宽敞
Lucia: And the second floor is not spacious enough.
Lucia: 如果我们五六个人的话不是很宽敞
Lucia: If there are five or six of us, it's not very spacious.
Tasha: 哎门怎么打开了
Tasha: Hey, why is the door open?
Alice:好喝
Alice: Tastes good.
Tasha: 好喝哈
Tasha: Yeah, tastes good.
Alice: 好了我结束了
Alice: Alright, I'm done.
Tasha: 啊你结束了
Tasha: Oh, you're done?
Alice: 哈哈对
Alice: Haha, yes.
Lucia:  我们可以想想
Lucia: We can think about it.
Lucia:  上面要什么花纹或者颜色的
Lucia: What patterns or colors we want on top.
Jake: 这什么曲子呀
Jake: What's this song?
Katrina:  奔跑的青春
Katrina: "Youth Running".
Katrina:  哈哈但是还没决定好几个
Katrina: Haha, but we haven't decided how many.
Katrina:  要看一下大家难度
Katrina: We need to see the difficulty for everyone.
Katrina:  猪猪侠那个有点慢我觉得
Katrina: I think the "Pig Hero" one is a bit slow.
Katrina:  拿筷子了吗
Katrina: Did you get the chopsticks?
Jake: 我又被diss了
Jake: I'm being dissed again.
Jake: 你又diss我哈哈
Jake: You're dissing me again, haha.
Jake: 总不回他的消息
Jake: Always not replying to his messages.
Jake: 他让我吃早饭
Jake: He tells me to have breakfast.
Jake: 牛啊就喊牛
Jake: Just call him "bull".
Tasha: 这还牛别看了
Tasha: That's not impressive, stop looking.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这锅烧导热性太好
Tasha: Hahaha, this pot conducts heat too well.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哦导多了
Jake: Oh, too much conduction.
Lucia:  我觉得这一看就很好吃
Lucia: I think this looks delicious.
Jake: 是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 不不会
Tasha: No, it won't be.
Jake: 为啥不会就会
Jake: Why not? It will be.
Lucia:  这个牛奶是你的了
Lucia: This milk is yours.
Tasha: 我没有信心
Tasha: I have no confidence.
Alice: 没事没事
Alice: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 试试试试
Jake: Try it, try it.
Lucia:  然后如果需要加咖啡请自行加
Lucia: And if you need to add coffee, add it yourself.
Lucia:  因为我不知道你要喝多浓
Lucia: Because I don't know how strong you want it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 好没关系
Jake: Alright, no problem.
Tasha: 加糖
Tasha: Add sugar.
Alice: 给你露西亚你的碗
Alice: Here you go, Lucia, your bowl.
Jake: 糖在哪
Jake: Where's the sugar?
Alice: 我拿一下吧
Alice: I'll grab it.
Tasha: 糖糖糖蘸糖
Tasha: Sugar, sugar, dip in sugar.
Lucia:  这个碗
Lucia: This bowl.
Lucia:  倒一个再拿一个好了
Lucia: Pour one and then take another.
Alice: 我我不要
Alice: I don't want it.
Alice: 我的已经结束了
Alice: I'm already done.
Lucia:  啊啊
Lucia: Ah, ah.
Alice: 我碗都刷完了
Alice: I've already washed my bowl.
Lucia:  那我就先拿走一个这个
Lucia: Then I'll just take one of these first.
Katrina:  不用加糖
Katrina: No need to add sugar.
Alice: 拿个纸擦一下
Alice: Get a tissue and wipe it.
Alice: 放放这个放糖吧
Alice: Put this, put the sugar in.
Jake: 要什么纸
Jake: What tissue?
Alice: 这这里面不是放糖蘸的吗
Alice: Isn't the sugar supposed to go in here?
Alice: 还是自己倒自己碗里
Alice: Or just pour it into your own bowl.
Tasha: 这是自己的碗
Tasha: This is your own bowl.
Katrina:  自己到自己碗里吧
Katrina: Just pour it into your own bowl.
Alice: 谁的碗
Alice: Whose bowl?
Katrina:  没人用就给他吧
Katrina: If no one's using it, give it to him.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 你自己倒吧要不
Alice: Why don't you pour it yourself then?
Alice: 我不知道你要多少
Alice: I don't know how much you want.
Alice: 你说停吧
Alice: You tell me when to stop.
Jake: 我我我来倒就好
Jake: I'll just pour it myself.
Jake: 为什么倒不下来
Jake: Why isn't it coming out?
Alice: 因为他有点受潮了
Alice: Because it's a bit damp.
Tasha: 这是绵白糖本来就这么绵
Tasha: This is caster sugar, it's supposed to be soft.
Jake: 哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake: 买的好挺好
Jake: Good purchase, very good.
Alice: 哦天哪跟谁
Alice: Oh my gosh, with whom?
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh man.
Alice: 分点吧
Alice: Let's split it.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 强行售卖
Jake: Forced sale.
Tasha: 哎哈哈
Tasha: Oh haha.
Alice: 你不得你给他弄碎点
Alice: You should crush it a bit for him.
Jake: 强行售卖
Jake: Forced sale.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Lucia: 这个里面就应该有糖的吗
Lucia: Should there be sugar in this?
Jake: 还要吗
Jake: Do you still need more?
Alice: 蘸糖吗
Alice: Dip it in sugar?
Jake: 分点
Jake: Share a bit.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 江苏人的
Alice: Like people from Jiangsu.
Jake: 分分你一点
Jake: I'll share a bit with you.
Lucia:  呃也可以
Lucia: Uh, that's fine.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 你这个倒太多了
Lucia: You poured too much.
Tasha: 对他骚太多了哈哈
Tasha: Yeah, he's being too extra, haha.
Jake: 对都都都是
Jake: Yeah, it's all too much.
Jake: 是我放太多了
Jake: I put in too much.
Alice: 你要糖吗雨轩
Alice: Do you want sugar, Yuxuan?
Tasha: 然后嗯贴面蘸
Tasha: And then, um, stand face to face.
Jake: 要吗好
Jake: Do you want it? Okay.
Katrina:  我不要糖
Katrina: I don't want sugar.
Jake: 你也不要
Jake: You don't want it either?
Alice: 我不吃糖
Alice: I don't eat sugar.
Alice: 我会流鼻血
Alice: It makes me have nosebleeds.
Jake: 啊确实
Jake: Ah, indeed.
Katrina:  这舞也行
Katrina: This dance is okay.
Tasha: 你要接受
Tasha: You have to accept it.
Lucia: 这个好像是我们那校庆
Lucia: This seems like our school celebration.
Katrina:  我高中跳过
Katrina: I danced this in high school.
Katrina:  高中晚会跳过
Katrina: During the high school party.
Lucia:  虽然我觉得动作可能不完全一样
Lucia: Although I think the moves might not be exactly the same.
Lucia:  但就这个背景音乐
Lucia: But this background music.
Katrina:  这个其实还行
Katrina: This is actually okay.
Katrina:  如果你能接受奔跑的青春的话
Katrina: If you can accept the youthful energy of running.
Katrina:  那你更加能接受这个
Katrina: Then you can accept this even more.
Katrina:  慢一点动作更简单
Katrina: The moves are simpler and slower.
Lucia: 就这个也可以
Lucia: This one is also fine.
Lucia:  这个鼓点也比较清晰
Lucia: The beat is quite clear.
Lucia: 就我喜欢这种
Lucia: I like this kind.
Alice: 不好不好
Alice: Not good, not good.
Lucia: 我能很快找到他的节奏的
Lucia: I can quickly find its rhythm.
Alice: 充电宝在哪
Alice: Where's the power bank?
Alice: 我这个可能快快要充电了
Alice: Mine might need charging soon.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 谁把我的充电宝拔走了
Tasha: Who took my power bank?
Alice: 你告诉我在哪我去拿就行了
Alice: Just tell me where it is, and I'll get it.
Jake: 我我来拿我来拿
Jake: I'll get it, I'll get it.
Alice: 味道怎么样
Alice: How does it taste?
Lucia: 很棒
Lucia: It's great.
Lucia: 特别好
Lucia: Really good.
Tasha: 我觉得用错面团了啊面粉了
Tasha: I think we used the wrong dough or flour.
Lucia: 那应该
Lucia: It should be...
Jake: 密度刚好
Jake: The density is just right.
Jake: 这这个面的密度刚好
Jake: This dough's density is just right.
Jake: 这是你的吗
Jake: Is this yours?
Jake: 这是这是这是
Jake: This... this... this...
Jake: 这是啥呀
Jake: What is this?
Alice: 这个不知道谁的
Alice: I don't know whose this is.
Alice: 这不是他的
Alice: It's not his.
Alice: 他的是个小蝴蝶
Alice: His has a little butterfly.
Jake: 这啥啊
Jake: What is this?
Alice: 不对小翅膀
Alice: No, it's a little wing.
Jake: 怎么看呢
Jake: How do you see it?
Alice: 不知道这是谁的
Alice: I don't know whose it is.
Lucia: 莫不是我的吗
Lucia: Could it be mine?
Jake: 是露西亚
Jake: It's Lucia's.
Alice: 啊姜
Alice: Ah, ginger.
Jake: 这这是姜
Jake: This is ginger.
Jake: 哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia: 嗯是
Lucia: Yes, it is.
Jake: 这是姜
Jake: This is ginger.
Jake: 哦哦哦哦哦哦好好
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, okay, okay.
Tasha: 好像
Tasha: Seems like it.
Jake: 那你要点
Jake: Do you want some?
Jake: 你也要点
Jake: Do you want some too?
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake: 就先放这些
Jake: Let's just put these first.
Katrina:  我觉得跳那个
Katrina: I think jumping that one...
Katrina:  不如跳这个
Katrina: is not as good as this one.
Alice: 味道还行吗
Alice: Does it taste okay?
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah, hahaha.
Katrina:  这还能3分钟呢
Katrina: This still has 3 minutes left.
Katrina:  这这动作都重复了
Katrina: These moves are all repeating.
Jake: 行这个比较明显
Jake: Okay, this one is more obvious.
Alice: 啊yes yes
Alice: Ah yes yes
Jake: 正好你坐着
Jake: Just in time, you're sitting down.
Katrina:  哦我要充电是吗
Katrina: Oh, do I need to charge?
Jake: 可以充一会
Jake: You can charge for a bit.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey
Jake: 是不不够啊
Jake: Is it not enough?
Katrina:  有一种机器人被连上电的感觉
Katrina: Feels like I'm a robot getting plugged in.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 连上之后记忆加速
Jake: Once plugged in, memory accelerates.
Jake: 1秒学舞
Jake: Learn dance in one second.
Katrina:  激活激活了
Katrina: Activation complete.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 这是谁的
Jake: Whose is this?
Tasha: 这个特别好吃
Tasha: This is really tasty.
Jake: 哈哈哈我
Jake: Hahaha, mine.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Jake: 我的是吧
Jake: It's mine, right?
Jake: 真的吗
Jake: Really?
Tasha: 真的这是第
Tasha: Yes, this is the first result.
Tasha: 一个成果
Tasha: The first product.
Jake: 真的哦真吃了
Jake: Really? You actually ate it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Lucia: 假吃了还能
Lucia: Pretending to eat it still...
Tasha: 别吃了吧哈哈
Tasha: Stop eating it, haha.
Jake: 刚刚那个猪猪侠是怎么跳的
Jake: Just now, how did Super Piggy dance?
Jake: 我很好奇
Jake: I'm really curious.
Katrina:  为啥特别简单
Katrina: Why? It's really simple.
Katrina:  就1234才做一个动作
Katrina: It's just 1, 2, 3, 4 for each move.
Lucia: 对这个比较简单哦
Lucia: Yeah, it's pretty simple.
Jake: 好好哎这个看一下
Jake: Okay, let's take a look at this.
Lucia: 她的节奏节奏感没有那么
Lucia: Her rhythm sense isn't that...
Lucia: 那么明确
Lucia: ...that clear.
Jake: 嗯确实有点呆
Jake: Yeah, she's a bit stiff.
Lucia: 那我们可以像雨轩说的
Lucia: Then we can do like Yuxuan said.
Lucia: 觉得比较可爱的造型
Lucia: 然后跳这个
Lucia: And dance this.
Jake: 可以都可以
Jake: Sure, we can do that.
Katrina:  人人都可以
Katrina: Everyone can do it.
Katrina:  一人带个蘑菇头跳那个蘑菇蘑菇
Katrina: Everyone with a mushroom haircut can dance the mushroom dance.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 啊哈哈
Lucia: Ahahaha
Lucia: 很有道理
Lucia: That makes sense.
Katrina:  嗯买两个头套就行
Katrina: Yeah, just buy two head covers.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 买个那那种气球
Jake: Buy one of those balloons.
Jake: 风吹起来
Jake: The kind that floats in the air.
Katrina:  造型的气球吗
Katrina: You mean a shaped balloon?
Katrina:  哦哦哦那个风吹那个人那个的
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh, the one that moves with the wind?
Lucia: 嗯是外卖到了吗
Lucia: Hmm, is the delivery here?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 不是外卖美团买药
Lucia: It's not delivery, it's from Meituan.
Jake: 来了
Jake: It's here.
Tasha: 嗯我以为午饭到了
Tasha: Hmm, I thought it was lunch.
Lucia: 喂你好
Lucia: Hello, hi.
Jake: 嗯嗯哼哼哼
Jake: Uh-huh, yeah, yeah.
Lucia:  呃我们是黄色铁门吗
Lucia: Uh, do we have a yellow iron gate?
Katrina:  现在在这
Katrina: Now it's here.
Katrina:  我听到他声音了
Katrina: I hear his voice.
Katrina:  他就在这
Katrina: He's right here.
Lucia: 哦这样子
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Lucia: 呃应该是同一个
Lucia: Uh, it should be the same one.
Lucia: 您稍等一下
Lucia: Please wait a moment.
Katrina:  是蓝绿色的
Katrina: It's turquoise.
Lucia: 是一个蓝绿色的建筑
Lucia: It's a turquoise building.
Alice: 薇薇这个饼你还满意吗
Alice: Tasha, are you happy with this pancake?
Tasha: 嗯煎的有点
Tasha: Hmm, it's a bit overcooked.
Alice: 还不错吧
Alice: It's not bad, right?
Tasha: 你吃了吗
Tasha: Have you tried it?
Alice: 没有啊
Alice: No, I haven't.
Tasha: 你还挺好的
Tasha: You're pretty good at this.
Alice: 那就行很棒
Alice: Well, that's great, it's awesome.
Tasha: 可见其实什么面粉并不重要
Tasha: Actually, the type of flour doesn't really matter.
Tasha: 那个锅的问题
Tasha: It's the pan's problem.
Alice: 过筛也可没没关系
Alice: Sifting it doesn't matter either.
Tasha: 那个锅的问题
Tasha: It's the pan's problem.
Jake: 你耳朵怎么这么好
Jake: How come your hearing is so good?
Jake: 还是隔音太差了
Jake: Or is the soundproofing too bad?
Katrina:  哈哈哈我刚以为你房间有人说话
Katrina: Hahaha, I thought someone was talking in your room.
Jake: 哦是这样
Jake: Oh, I see.
Jake: 怎么去郑州
Jake: How do I get to Zhengzhou?
Tasha: 哎你怎么是吧
Tasha: Hey, what are you...
Jake: 你刚刚打电话说的
Jake: You just called and said...
Jake: 去干嘛呀
Jake: What are you going to do there?
Alice: 跟我约会
Alice: Go on a date with me.
Jake: 哦可以
Jake: Oh, sure.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  你要去郑州吗
Katrina: Are you going to Zhengzhou?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  你去郑州干啥开会吗
Katrina: What are you going to Zhengzhou for? A meeting?
Tasha: 去玩五一
Tasha: Going to have fun for May Day.
Jake: 五一去郑州
Jake: Going to Zhengzhou for May Day?
Jake: 可以人会很多吧
Jake: There will be a lot of people, right?
Alice: 啊你去郑州
Alice: Ah, you're going to Zhengzhou?
Alice: 不是你郑州去哪啊
Alice: No, where in Zhengzhou are you going?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know yet.
Katrina:  哈哈哈我有个舍友也是郑州
Katrina: Hahaha, I have a roommate from Zhengzhou too.
Alice: 你去
Alice: You go...
Lucia: 本地人
Lucia: Local person.
Alice: 你问我吧问我吧
Alice: Ask me, ask me!
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah...
Tasha: 我不知道去哪呢还
Tasha: I still don't know where to go.
Tasha: 他们安排我
Tasha: They're planning for me.
Tasha: 我可是个P人
Tasha: I'm just a nobody.
Alice: 我的天啊
Alice: Oh my god.
Alice: 我觉得去哪玩我都理解不了
Alice: I can't understand where to go for fun.
Katrina:  完了
Katrina: It's over.
Lucia: 我只有碰到比我更P的朋友的时候
Lucia: Only when I meet friends who are even more laid-back than me...
Alice: 带你去洛阳
Alice: I'll take you to Luoyang.
Lucia: 我才会做计划
Lucia: Only then I make plans.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈你去洛阳跟开封都挺近的
Alice: Hahaha, going to Luoyang and Kaifeng is pretty close.
Alice: 从郑州东站出发哈哈哈
Alice: Start from Zhengzhou East Station, hahaha.
Katrina:  郑州最好玩的就是郑州东站
Katrina: The most fun place in Zhengzhou is Zhengzhou East Station.
Alice: 郑州东站哈哈
Alice: Zhengzhou East Station, haha.
Katrina:  买一张票去别的地方
Katrina: Buy a ticket to go somewhere else.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Alice: 我跟你说一下
Alice: Let me tell you something.
Alice: 超级好吃的那种甜水铺你可以去
Alice: There's this really delicious sweet water shop you can go to.
Tasha: 啊你说吧
Tasha: Ah, you go ahead.
Jake: 好你说吧
Jake: Alright, go on.
Tasha: 我让万一我不去他们能吃
Tasha: I mean, in case I don't go, they can still eat.
Alice: 我觉得那一栋楼只有
Alice: I think that building only has...
Alice: 就是为数不多的几家活着
Alice: Just a few families still living there.
Tasha: 你说
Tasha: You say it.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake: 这个咖啡我是怎么搞啊
Jake: How do I make this coffee?
Alice: 直接啊浓缩液倒进去往上拔
Alice: Just pour in the concentrate and pull it up.
Katrina:  就一条拔出来
Katrina: Just pull out one strip.
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Alice: 就是大上海城
Alice: That's in the Shanghai City.
Jake: 有点多哎
Jake: That's a bit much.
Tasha: 啊上海城然后呢
Tasha: Ah, Shanghai City, and then what?
Katrina:  倒进来就这么
Katrina: Just pour it in like this.
Alice: 东东鲜芋圆
Alice: Dong Dong Fresh Taro Balls.
Alice: 东西南北的东
Alice: "Dong" as in east.
Tasha: 东东鲜芋圆好了
Tasha: Dong Dong Fresh Taro Balls, got it.
Alice: 嗯东东鲜芋圆就他们家巨好吃
Alice: Yeah, Dong Dong Fresh Taro Balls, their stuff is super tasty.
Alice: 你会发现
Alice: You'll find...
Alice: 那个商城基本上是倒闭的状态
Alice: That mall is basically shut down.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice: 哎
Alice: Hey.
Alice: 你五一要真的去的话你可以来我家玩
Alice: If you really come over on May Day, you can hang out at my place.
Alice: 真的你要不住我家吧
Alice: Really, why don't you stay at my place?
Katrina:  节省了一笔房费
Katrina: Save on hotel costs.
Alice: 真的你要不住我家吧
Alice: Really, why don't you stay at my place?
Alice: 我家也没啥人
Alice: My place isn't crowded.
Jake: 你你还能带几个人
Jake: How many people can you bring?
Jake: 哈哈哈住几个人
Jake: Hahaha, how many people can stay?
Tasha: 能住几个哈哈
Tasha: How many can stay? Haha.
Alice: 啊哈啊你有几个
Alice: Ah, how many do you have?
Lucia: 对我这离你家很近
Lucia: Yeah, I'm really close to your place.
Alice: 我也可以去网吧
Alice: I can go to the internet cafe too.
Lucia: 我也可以住两个人吧
Lucia: I can host two people too.
Tasha: 我天呐哈哈
Tasha: Oh my gosh, haha.
Alice: 来吧来吧
Alice: Come on, come on.
Alice: 你你们有几个人
Alice: How many of you are there?
Lucia: 一只手
Lucia: One hand's worth.
Tasha: 应该是3个到4个
Tasha: Should be around three to four.
Tasha: 呃 4个到5个吧
Tasha: Uh, about 4 to 5.
Alice: 啊把我第
Alice: Ah, then kick me out.
Alice: 赶出家门
Alice: Kick me out of the house.
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈嗯
Tasha: Ah hahahahahahahahaha
Alice: 让他让他不许回来
Alice: And don't let him come back.
Alice: 然后就可以腾出来房间住了
Alice: Then we can free up a room to live in.
Alice: 笑死
Alice: That's hilarious.
Tasha: 月18号8点开始抢票
Tasha: Tickets go on sale at 8 PM on the 18th.
Tasha: 怎么什么都要抢
Tasha: Why do we have to fight for everything?
Jake: 五一要抢票是吧
Jake: We have to fight for tickets for May Day, right?
Jake: 完了五一那会儿我回新加坡
Jake: Well, I'm going back to Singapore for May Day.
Jake: 是不是特别贵
Jake: Is it really expensive?
Jake: 呵呵呵我没订票
Jake: Haha, I haven't booked the tickets.
Katrina:  还没订票
Katrina: You haven't booked yet.
Jake:P人不会订票
Jake: People don't know how to book tickets.
Alice: 我五一要回家了
Alice: I'm going home for May Day.
Alice: 我现在还没开始定
Alice: I haven't started booking yet.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈连我一个P都觉得震惊
Lucia: Haha, even someone like me is shocked.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake: 呵呵我上了飞
Jake: Haha, I get on the plane.
Jake: 先去飞机场再买票
Jake: Buy the ticket at the airport.
Katrina:  嗯我是受不了
Katrina: I can't handle that.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 啊什么
Alice: What?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because...
Tasha: 先去飞机场再买票
Tasha: Buy the ticket at the airport first.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 因为这比较省钱
Jake: Because it's cheaper.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 因为如果我提前买票通常赶不上飞机
Jake: Because if I buy tickets in advance, I usually miss the flight.
Jake: 所以就要改签
Jake: So I have to reschedule.
Alice: 原来是这样
Alice: Oh, I see.
Alice: 我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Katrina:  但是你到那买不是很贵吗
Katrina: But isn't it very expensive to buy there?
Katrina:  有的时候
Katrina: Sometimes.
Jake: 但是我每次都赶不上飞机
Jake: But I always miss the flight.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 是原来是这样
Alice: Oh, so that's how it is.
Katrina:  受不了你了真的
Katrina: I really can't stand you.
Jake: 对所以比较省钱
Jake: Yeah, so it's more economical.
Alice: 这是能说的吗
Alice: Is this something we can say?
Alice: 给外国人一点震撼哈
Alice: Give the foreigners a bit of a shock, huh?
Katrina:  嘿嘿嘿
Katrina: Hehehe.
Alice:笑死
Alice: Laughing to death.
Jake: 这个可以说吧
Jake: This should be okay to say, right?
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 以前试了很多次教训
Jake: I tried many times before and learned my lesson.
Jake: 就是每次都可能提前40分钟check in
Jake: Every time I would check in like 40 minutes early.
Jake: 然后我可能就3938分钟到
Jake: And then I might arrive 39 or 38 minutes early.
Jake: 然后呵呵呵
Jake: And then, haha.
Jake: 就很失望
Jake: It was very disappointing.
Jake: 以后就不买票了
Jake: So I stopped buying tickets.
Alice: 呵我第一次听说
Alice: This is the first time I've heard this.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 是不是很让人震惊
Lucia: Isn't it quite shocking?
Alice: 我觉得我已经很很那啥了
Alice: I thought I was already quite something.
Jake: 哎路亚你这个关了
Jake: Hey, Lucia, you turned it off.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Jake: 是哎为什么会关
Jake: Yeah, why did you turn it off?
Alice: 嗯充电
Alice: Hmm, charging.
Lucia: 啊有充着电呢
Lucia: Ah, it's charging.
Jake: 看一下看一下
Jake: Check it, check it.
Jake: 什么什么
Jake: What, what?
Tasha: 说不出话来
Tasha: I'm speechless.
Tasha: 还是钱太多了还是还是钱太多了
Tasha: Still, too much money, still too much money.
Alice: 震惊了
Alice: I'm shocked.
Lucia: 他被你吓着了
Lucia: He got scared by you.
Jake: 不是没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 还是要省钱
Jake: Still need to save money.
Tasha: 还是钱太多了家里
Tasha: Still too much money at home.
Jake: 还是不能白花钱
Jake: Still can't waste money.
Jake: 就是可以贵一点
Jake: It can be a bit more expensive.
Jake: 但是不能白花钱
Jake: But can't waste money.
Tasha: 还是家里钱太多了
Tasha: Still too much money at home.
Katrina:  笑死我了
Katrina: I'm dying of laughter.
Lucia: 他又变白了
Lucia: He turned pale again.
Lucia: 但是我没有关
Lucia: But I didn't turn it off.
Lucia:  我的它是自动
Lucia: Mine is automatic.
Tasha: 啊哈哈
Tasha: Ahaha.
Lucia:  关闭了吗
Lucia: Is it turned off?
Tasha: 接完接电话是不是会自动关
Tasha: Does it turn off automatically after you finish a call?
Lucia: 应该会影响吧
Lucia: It should affect it, right?
Jake: 应该不会
Jake: It shouldn't.
Lucia:  哎他好像真的刚才那圈突然掉线了
Lucia: Oh, it really seemed to disconnect suddenly just now.
Lucia: 那我再来一个
Lucia: Let me try again.
Alice: 薇薇，你们那个规划我真的很好奇
Alice: 我也想知道郑州有啥玩的
Alice: I also want to know what's fun in Zhengzhou.
Tasha: 不知道呀玩啥呀
Tasha: No idea, what is there to do?
Katrina:  看下外地人做的攻略你就知道
Katrina: Check out the guides made by outsiders and you'll know.
Alice: 对对对哈哈哈
Alice: Yeah, yeah, hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Tasha: 我什么都不知道
Tasha: I don't know anything.
Tasha: 就今天打电话说去郑州玩嘛
Tasha: Just got a call today saying to go to Zhengzhou.
Tasha: 哈哈我说有空我就去
Tasha: Haha, I said I'd go if I had time.
Alice: 是不是你们要去演唱会之类的
Alice: Are you guys going to a concert or something?
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Alice: 是吗我不知道啊
Alice: Really? I didn't know.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Katrina:  你怎么不来武汉玩
Katrina: Why don't you come to Wuhan?
Tasha: 武汉
Tasha: Wuhan?
Tasha: 没有人邀请我去
Tasha: No one invited me.
Katrina:  觉得武汉还是我邀请你
Katrina: I think Wuhan is better, so I'm inviting you.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Katrina:  武汉比郑州好玩一点点
Katrina: Wuhan is a bit more fun than Zhengzhou.
Lucia: 我还没去过郑州
Lucia: I've never been to Zhengzhou.
Tasha: 我也没有去过
Tasha: Me neither.
Katrina:  武汉但是武汉五一人应该很多
Katrina: But Wuhan should be crowded during Labor Day.
Alice: 来吧来找我吧
Alice: Come on, come visit me.
Alice: 我五一应该在家
Alice: I'll probably be home during Labor Day.
Alice: 我也没开始订票
Alice: I haven't started booking tickets yet.
Alice: 我一看那个票售罄了
Alice: I saw the tickets were sold out.
Alice: 然后我还没开始订
Alice: So I haven't started booking.
Lucia:  行那果然是全员批人
Lucia: Well, everyone's procrastinating as usual.
Alice: 无所谓反正
Alice: It doesn't matter anyway.
Alice: 嗯买不到票就只能
Alice: If I can't get tickets, then I just...
Lucia: 我也经常会提前两三天才订
Lucia: I also often book just two or three days in advance.
Lucia: 但是嗯您知道吗哈哈哈
Lucia: But, um, you know? Hahaha
Jake: 一般大概也就提前两个小时对
Jake: Usually, it's about two hours in advance.
Lucia: 比较厉害的了
Lucia: That's pretty impressive.
Jake: 就提前两个小时就能有飞机
Jake: Just two hours in advance and you can get a flight.
Alice: 第一次听说
Alice: First time hearing this.
Alice: 真的闻所未闻
Alice: Really unheard of.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 到了机场一看那个板我觉得这个不错
Jake: When I got to the airport and saw the board, I thought this was not bad.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake: 看看多少钱
Jake: Let's see how much it costs.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈闻所未闻
Alice: Hahahahaha, really unheard of.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 大开眼界
Lucia: Really eye-opening.
Alice: 我觉得
Alice: I think
Alice: 我提前一两天买票已经挺极限了
Alice: Buying tickets one or two days in advance is already my limit.
Alice: 就是别人可能他一放票
Alice: I mean, others might start as soon as the tickets are released.
Alice: 或者说是提前几天就是放票的
Alice: Or a few days before the release date.
Alice: 提前几天
Alice: A few days in advance.
Alice: 可能就一共推往前推个一二十天
Alice: They could be looking at about ten to twenty days in advance.
Alice: 就开始抢了
Alice: And then start snatching.
Alice: 然后我大学的时候也是
Alice: When I was in college,
Alice: 他们都已经开始想
Alice: They were already planning
Alice: 哪天抢哪天的票了
Alice: Which day's tickets to grab.
Alice: 然后每次都是快回家了
Alice: And every time it was almost time to go home,
Alice: 我想要不看看票吧
Alice: I thought, why not check the tickets?
Alice: 一看啦啦啦售罄哈哈哈
Alice: And then, sold out, hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈是
Jake: Haha, yes.
Alice: 好吧
Alice: Alright.
Jake: 是有一次我回家飞南京然后
Jake: There was one time I was flying back home to Nanjing, and
Jake: 就没赶上嘛
Jake: I missed it.
Jake: 自然而然没有赶上
Jake: Naturally, I missed it.
Jake: 呃那一天最后
Jake: That day was the last
Tasha: 哈哈哈自然而然没赶上
Tasha: Hahaha, naturally missed it.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈自然而然没有赶上
Lucia: 哈哈哈这个是我最爱
Lucia: Hahaha, this is my favorite.
Jake: 对自然而然没有赶上
Jake: Yes, naturally missed it.
Jake: 所以所以那天看的最后一班
Jake: So, that day, I watched the last flight
Jake: 回中国了
Jake: back to China.
Jake: 先到了成都
Jake: First, we arrived in Chengdu.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 对到了成都待了一晚上
Jake: Yeah, we stayed a night in Chengdu.
Jake: 我觉得成都到南京应该高铁也挺快
Jake: I thought the high-speed train from Chengdu to Nanjing would be quick.
Tasha: 然后也没赶上
Tasha: And we missed it.
Katrina:  很很远很远
Katrina: It's really, really far.
Katrina:  1,800公里
Katrina: 1,800 kilometers.
Jake: 对我我我以为挺快的
Jake: Yeah, I thought it would be fast.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake: 因为我想北京也挺
Jake: Because I thought Beijing was also...
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake: 就差不多距离吧
Jake: ...about the same distance, right?
Jake: 对吧大概有几个小时
Jake: About a few hours, right?
Tasha: 啊然后赶上好吗
Tasha: So, did you catch it?
Jake: 结果要那个是飞机场买的所以
Jake: The thing is, we bought the tickets at the airport, so...
Jake: 赶上哈哈哈哈
Jake: We managed to catch it, hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake: 就是去到成都之对那
Jake: So, we went to Chengdu and then...
Jake: 那个是买到了成都之后
Jake: After we bought the tickets in Chengdu...
Jake: 一晚上就在这个春熙路晃悠了一晚上
Jake: We wandered around Chunxi Road for a night.
Jake: 然后因为第二天早上的飞机
Jake: Because we had an early flight the next morning.
Jake: 然后就飞走了
Jake: Then we flew out.
Jake: 原来想坐高铁的
Jake: Initially, we wanted to take the high-speed train.
Jake: 结果
Jake: But...
Jake: 那个高铁大概也得七八个小时是吧
Jake: The high-speed train would have taken about seven or eight hours, right?
Katrina:  没有高铁
Katrina: There's no high-speed train.
Katrina:  成都到武汉都要9个小时
Katrina: It takes 9 hours from Chengdu to Wuhan.
Katrina:  武汉到南京还要2 3个小时
Katrina: And another 2-3 hours from Wuhan to Nanjing.
Alice: 它那个线路不一定
Alice: The route isn't fixed.
Katrina:  但是但是10小时以上
Katrina: But it's over 10 hours.
Jake: 太可怕了
Jake: That's scary.
Katrina:  我一般都是买的飞机票
Katrina: I usually buy plane tickets.
Katrina:  我当时也以为
Katrina: I used to think...
Katrina:  我以为那个武汉长沙
Katrina: I thought Wuhan and Changsha...
Katrina:  成都是挨在一起的
Katrina: ...were close to Chengdu.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  武汉跟长沙只有一个小时
Katrina: It's only an hour from Wuhan to Changsha.
Katrina:  但是到到川渝那就很远
Katrina: But getting to Sichuan and Chongqing is far.
Katrina:  就要6个小时
Katrina: It takes about 6 hours.
Jake: 要绕一圈
Jake: You have to go around in a loop.
Jake: 我也觉得应该挺近
Jake: I also think it should be pretty close.
Jake: 我也觉得这个中国高铁应该没这么
Jake: I also think the Chinese high-speed rail shouldn't be this...
Jake: 没这么慢
Jake: ...slow.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Jake: 我高铁有十几个小时
Jake: My high-speed rail takes more than ten hours.
Lucia: 虽然成都到武汉比成都到北京还慢
Lucia: Although it's slower from Chengdu to Wuhan than from Chengdu to Beijing.
Lucia: 总感觉好像
Lucia: It always feels like...
Lucia: 感觉上应该就是他到北京更远一些
Lucia: It feels like Beijing is farther away.
Alice: 现高铁是不是降过速了
Alice: Did they slow down the high-speed rail?
Alice: 现在高铁是不是降过速了
Alice: Did they slow it down?
Alice: 现在一般都300多了
Alice: Now it's usually over 300 km/h.
Jake: 对都是300对
Jake: Yes, it's all around 300 km/h.
Alice: 嗯都是300多
Alice: Hmm, all over 300.
Jake: 300整怎么
Jake: Exactly 300, how...
Tasha: 太离谱了
Tasha: That's ridiculous.
Tasha: 他帮我找出来了北京到郑州的公交票
Tasha: He helped me find a bus ticket from Beijing to Zhengzhou.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Jake: 倒多少趟
Jake: How many transfers?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Alice: 告诉我哈哈
Alice: Tell me, haha.
Tasha: 我说我说如果我不去
Tasha: I said, if I don't go...
Jake: 哎狭路共赏
Jake: Oh, narrow path.
Tasha: 我说我说如果我24号去北京
Tasha: I said, if I go to Beijing on the 24th...
Tasha: 我他说不去打死我
Tasha: He said he wouldn't go even if you kill him.
Alice: 不去打死
Alice: Wouldn't go even if...
Tasha: 我说住哪
Tasha: I asked where to stay...
Tasha: 然后他说麻麻利利的把公交票订下来
Tasha: Then he quickly booked the bus ticket.
Tasha: 哈哈啊
Tasha: Haha, ah.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你朋友是真人吗
Lucia: Hahaha, is your friend even real?
Alice: 啊我的天
Alice: Oh my god.
Jake: 北京任意点
Jake: Any point in Beijing.
Katrina:  不是怎么坐公交来这啊
Katrina: How do you take a bus from there?
Jake: 啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Tasha: 北京任意点到郑州
Tasha: From any point in Beijing to Zhengzhou.
Lucia: 是可以坐公交去郑州
Lucia: Can you really take a bus to Zhengzhou?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice: 我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Tasha: 上门接送
Tasha: Door-to-door service
Lucia: 上门接送
Lucia: Door-to-door service
Jake: 哈哈上
Jake: Haha, door-to-door
Katrina:  我去
Katrina: I'll go
Alice: 我的天呐哈哈哈
Alice: Oh my god, hahaha
Jake: 专车是吧
Jake: Private car, right?
Jake: 专车才280
Jake: Private car for only 280
Lucia: 对我也想问
Lucia: Yeah, I was going to ask
Lucia:  这么便宜啊
Lucia: So cheap?
Alice: 比我高铁还便宜
Alice: Cheaper than my high-speed train
Alice: 但是时间太长了屁股要坐烂了
Alice: But it takes so long, my butt will be sore
Tasha: 10个小时
Tasha: 10 hours
Tasha: 唉那好吧
Tasha: Sigh, well okay then
Lucia:  咱在国内也没必要
Lucia: There's no need for that domestically
Lucia: 做什么fuss或者哈哈哈
Lucia: To make such a fuss, hahaha
Lucia: 会所BUS这种东西
Lucia: Things like club buses
Tasha: 到那再说开宾馆
Tasha: We'll book a hotel when we get there
Alice: 我看看
Alice: Let me see
Alice: 绝了
Alice: Amazing
Alice: 不是他是怎么能想到这条路的
Alice: How did he even think of this route?
Alice: 我真是闻所未闻
Alice: I've never heard of this before
Tasha: 他一会让我骑自行车过去哈哈哈
Tasha: He wants me to ride a bike there, hahaha
Alice: 你骑个小黄
Alice: You ride a Nicous
Jake: 北京到郑州自行车骑多久
Jake: How long does it take to bike from Beijing to Zhengzhou?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: I don't know
Lucia:  到地了都当地的小黄
Lucia: By the time you get there, you’ll be a local Nicous
Jake: 就是五一
Jake: Just for Labor Day
Lucia: 接收站都不接收他
Lucia: Even the reception won’t accept him
Alice: 调度费太贵了哈哈
Alice: The scheduling fee is too expensive, haha
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes
Tasha: 那我要用那种第一次的手机号去注册
Tasha: Then I’ll have to use a new phone number to register
Tasha: 然后他说新人首次可以免费调度
Tasha: And he said new users get free scheduling for the first time
Lucia: 哈哈哈你可以每路上每到一个城市
Lucia: Hahaha, you can change to a new Nicous in every city you pass
Lucia: 换一辆小黄
Lucia: Between neighboring cities
Lucia: 就挨着的城市之间
Lucia: Just between the cities
Tasha: 不是你在思考这件事的可行性吗
Tasha: Are you really considering the feasibility of this?
Tasha: 我到那要不要先治腿
Tasha: Should I treat my legs first when I get there?
Alice: 天哪
Alice: Oh my god
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Alice: 为了盘醋包了盘饺子
Alice: I made dumplings just to go with the vinegar.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Alice: 太好笑了
Alice: That's hilarious.
Lucia: 为了保证你能顺利顺利去郑州啊
Lucia: Just to make sure you can enjoy the pearls, right?
Alice: 闻所未闻
Alice: Never heard of that before.
Jake: 导航郑州哪个医院好
Jake: Navigate to the best hospital in Zhengzhou.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake: 骨科
Jake: Orthopedics.
Tasha: 我懂了就这样子
Tasha: I get it, just like that.
Tasha: 我在中途然后摔倒了
Tasha: I fell halfway through.
Tasha: 然后郑州开救护车过来接我哈哈哈
Tasha: Then Zhengzhou sent an ambulance to pick me up, hahaha.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice: 哎压住了谁手机
Alice: Hey, who's phone did I sit on?
Alice: 郑州确实有
Alice: Zhengzhou really has...
Alice: 骨科医院
Alice: An orthopedic hospital.
Alice: 离东站不是很远
Alice: It's not far from the east station.
Alice: 可以到了直接去哈哈
Alice: You can go there directly, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 也不用去宾馆了是吧哈哈哈
Lucia: No need to go to a hotel, right? Haha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: yeah
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 五一
Jake: May Day.
Jake: 五一放几天
Jake: How many days off for May Day?
Alice: 没看
Alice: Didn't check.
Jake: 7天吧
Jake: Probably 7 days off.
Lucia: 少说5天嗯
Alice: 休不够就请假
Alice: If not enough, just take leave.
Lucia: 你你还可以大胆一点
Lucia: You can be more bold.
Tasha: 你你
Tasha: You, you...
Lucia: 休不够就翘课
Lucia: If not enough, just skip class.
Tasha: 对啊我今天就翘课了
Tasha: Yeah, I skipped class today.
Jake: 什么课啊
Jake: What class?
Tasha: 什么课不重要
Tasha: What class doesn't matter.
Tasha: 我其实没见过他呢哈哈
Tasha: Actually, I've never met him, haha.
Alice:你要跳舞吗
Alice: Do you want to dance?
Jake: 好多人啊哈哈哈
Jake: So many people, haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Alice: 好多人啊
Alice: So many people
Alice: 我看最近有什么演唱会的票今天晚上可以开始抢了
Alice: I'm checking what concert tickets are available, they go on sale tonight
Katrina:  135
Katrina: 135
Tasha: 在北京的医院居然要抢
Tasha: Even in Beijing hospitals, you have to fight for it
Tasha: 抢票你知道吗
Tasha: Do you know about fighting for tickets?
Tasha: 就是要提前7天的时候就要开始抢
Tasha: You have to start fighting for them 7 days in advance
Lucia: 哎我明明充电它为什么又变成低电量
Lucia: Hey, I clearly charged it, why is it low battery again?
Tasha: 那个医治的号
Tasha: The treatment number
Jake: 那个我看一下
Jake: Let me check
Alice: 是的是的对
Alice: Yes, yes, exactly
Tasha: 挂号费咋这么贵 100块钱
Tasha: Why is the registration fee so expensive? 100 yuan
Alice: 你挂的是什么号啊
Alice: What kind of number did you register for?
Katrina:  怎么又有SOLO啊
Katrina: How come there's another solo?
Tasha: 专家号
Tasha: Specialist number
Alice: 那专家号是会贵一点
Alice: Specialist numbers are a bit more expensive
Alice: 你会发现专家号也就给你诊疗个
Alice: You'll find that the specialist number will just give you a diagnosis
Lucia: 可是我刚办上的时候他还30%
Lucia: But when I first started, it was still at 30%
Lucia: 但是中间有那么一小一小段时间没插
Lucia: But there was a short period when it wasn't plugged in
Alice:一 点点时间
Alice: A little bit of time
Tasha: 还有那种急诊预约挂号
Tasha: There’s also emergency appointment registration
Tasha: 500块钱一个号
Tasha: 500 yuan per number
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 我给你调个电多的
Jake: I’ll get you one with more power
Alice: 急诊
Alice: Emergency
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm
Alice: 急诊还得预约
Alice: Even emergencies need appointments?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Yeah
Alice: 都急诊了为什么还要预约呢
Alice: If it's an emergency, why do you need an appointment?
Tasha: 就是紧急急诊预约号
Tasha: It's an urgent emergency appointment number
Tasha: 500块一个人
Tasha: 500 yuan per person
Jake: 嗯给你一个这个大的
Jake: Here, I’ll give you this big one
Jake: 就是大的
Jake: It's big
Alice: 暂时还没有遇到过急诊的情况
Alice: I haven't encountered an emergency situation yet
Jake: 贵的
Jake: Expensive
Tasha: 我们学校
Tasha: At our school
Tasha: 校医院挂号都一块钱
Tasha: The school hospital registration is just 1 yuan
Tasha: 你们学校也是是吧
Tasha: It's the same at your school, right?
Alice: 因为有补助是吧嗯
Alice: Because there are subsidies, right? Mm-hmm
Lucia: 我们学校医院刚开始就只要5毛钱
Lucia: Our school hospital just needed 0.5 yuan at the beginning
Jake: 换一个
Jake: Change it.
Lucia: 后来加到两块钱
Lucia: 好过分啊
Lucia: That's too much.
Tasha: 那那是一块钱我
Tasha: That was one yuan for me.
Jake: 对要保证上面的灯一直是亮着的
Jake: Yes, we need to make sure the light stays on.
Jake: 他才能充
Jake: Only then it can charge.
Alice: 张惠妹
Alice: A-Mei Zhang
Tasha: 然后每次开的药都需要提个麻袋去
Tasha: And every time I get medicine, I need to bring a big sack.
Tasha: 去提是吧
Tasha: To carry it, right?
Tasha: 哈哈是吧
Tasha: Haha, right?
Lucia:  哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 对是的他给你开药都是10盒起开
Tasha: Yes, they prescribe at least 10 boxes each time.
Lucia: 没有这么夸张
Lucia: It's not that exaggerated.
Tasha: 这没有那么夸张吗
Tasha: It's not that exaggerated?
Lucia: 你是使用了夸张的修辞手法吗
Lucia: Are you using hyperbole?
Tasha: 哈哈没有使用夸张学法
Tasha: Haha, no hyperbole.
Tasha: 我比如说呃我最近有点感冒
Tasha: For example, if I have a cold,
Tasha: 他会给我开说哪里感冒
Tasha: they ask where does it hurt.
Tasha: 你喉咙疼不疼
Tasha: Does your throat hurt?
Tasha: 我如果说喉咙疼
Tasha: If I say my throat hurts,
Tasha: 他会给我开喉咙疼的药
Tasha: they prescribe throat medicine.
Tasha: 喷喉咙的药
Tasha: Throat spray.
Tasha: 感冒灵颗粒解毒胶囊
Tasha: Cold granules and detox capsules.
Tasha: 哈哈开到一盒一种药就要开两三盒
Tasha: Haha, and for each type, they prescribe two or three boxes.
Tasha: 那种可能就就不要钱吧
Tasha: Maybe those are free.
Tasha: 然后他就一直开
Tasha: And they just keep prescribing.
Jake: 头疼医脑
Jake: Cure the head for a headache.
Lucia: 头疼医全身
Lucia: Cure the whole body for a headache.
Jake: 嗯哈哈
Jake: Hmm, haha.
Alice: 今年没有抢到一张票
Alice: I didn't get a single ticket this year.
Jake: 什么票
Jake: What ticket?
Tasha: 抢什么票
Tasha: What ticket are you talking about?
Alice: 演唱会的一张没抢到
Alice: Not a single concert ticket.
Jake: 都有啥呀
Jake: What concerts are there?
Katrina:  我都找代抢了
Katrina: I even used a proxy.
Lucia:  让
Lucia: Let
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah
Lucia: 让杨老板
Lucia: Let Jake
Lucia:  用他的那些设备
Lucia: use his equipment.
Tasha: 设备帮你抢
Tasha: to help you grab tickets.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Alice: 啊可以吗
Alice: Oh, can we?
Tasha: 开启加速器
Tasha: Turn on the accelerator.
Jake: 开启7台电脑
Jake: Turn on 7 computers.
Katrina:  要搞一个Python脚本
Katrina: We need to create a Python script.
Lucia: 是因为他电脑多了
Lucia: It's because he has too many computers.
Jake: 哈哈哈一样的
Jake: Hahaha, same thing.
Jake: 那你猜这台电脑
Jake: So, guess this computer.
Jake: 就是这些电脑每一台都都是租的
Jake: All these computers are rented.
Jake: 然后租了十天
Jake: And rented for ten days.
Jake: 每一台多少钱
Jake: How much for each?
Jake: 你猜就是十天多少钱
Jake: Guess how much for ten days.
Jake: 一台
Jake: For one.
Tasha: 多少钱一台多少钱
Tasha: How much for one, how much?
Jake: 给个数给个数字吧
Jake: Give a number, just a number.
Lucia: 应该不会太贵吧否则的话他就会买
Lucia: It shouldn't be too expensive, otherwise, he would buy them.
Tasha: 一百块钱
Tasha: A hundred bucks.
Katrina:  我们学校竟然跳过这舞
Katrina: Our school actually danced this.
Jake: 差不多
Jake: Close enough.
Tasha: 我把我电脑借给你吧
Tasha: I'll lend you my computer.
Jake: 哈哈哈十天80啊
Jake: Hahaha, ten days for 80.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: What?
Lucia: 十天80
Lucia: Ten days for 80.
Jake: 十天80
Jake: Ten days for 80.
Tasha: 80一天
Tasha: 80 per day?
Jake: 十天一个电脑
Jake: Ten days for one computer.
Jake: 一台电脑八十
Jake: One computer for 80.
Tasha: 10天
Tasha: 10 days.
Alice: 一天8块钱吗
Alice: So, 8 bucks a day?
Tasha: 一天才8块钱
Tasha: Only 8 bucks a day.
Jake: 对一台电脑一天8块钱
Jake: Yes, one computer, 8 bucks a day.
Alice: 还挺便宜
Alice: That's pretty cheap.
Jake: 可以不租了是吧
Jake: Can we not rent it anymore?
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 啊没有啊
Tasha: No, not really.
Jake: 也可以租
Jake: We can still rent.
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Really?
Katrina:  今天刷的这个5
Katrina: Today we cleaned this up.
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh.
Katrina:  是我们计算机艺术团的
Katrina: It's for our computer arts group.
Katrina:  还是我们学校的
Katrina: Still from our school.
Tasha:才 80块钱10天
Tasha: Only 80 yuan for 10 days.
Katrina:  我学姐在杭州上班哈哈
Katrina: My senior is working in Hangzhou, haha.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 那我以后打游戏要不不买电脑了
Tasha: Then maybe I won't buy a computer for gaming anymore.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Tasha: 去租电脑吧
Tasha: I'll just rent a computer.
Katrina:  这是他那年的毕业晚会
Katrina: This was his graduation party that year.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  他大四我大一
Katrina: He was a senior, and I was a freshman.
Lucia: 哈哈但是我觉得
Lucia: Haha, but I think...
Jake: 哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Lucia: 他租的电脑可能没有那么高配置
Lucia: The computer he rented might not have high specs.
Katrina:  居然
Katrina: Can't believe it.
Tasha: 哦垃圾电脑
Tasha: Oh, a trash computer.
Katrina:  我4年前就跳过你
Katrina: I danced past you 4 years ago.
Katrina:  要跳舞吗哈哈
Katrina: Wanna dance? Haha.
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: No idea.
Tasha: 弟弟得了一个怪病
Tasha: My little brother got a strange illness.
Tasha: 要来北京治
Tasha: He needs to come to Beijing for treatment.
Tasha: 他在我们县医院治不好
Tasha: He can't be treated in our county hospital.
Tasha: 在扬州市医院治不好
Tasha: Can't be treated in Yangzhou city hospital.
Tasha: 在南京市医院也治不好
Tasha: Can't be treated in Nanjing city hospital either.
Katrina:  这太难了
Katrina: This is so difficult.
Tasha: 然后要来北京医院寻医
Tasha: So we have to seek treatment in a Beijing hospital.
Alice: 他怎么了
Alice: What's wrong with him?
Tasha: 他长不高
Tasha: He's not growing taller.
Jake: 长不高
Jake: Not growing taller?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  多大了
Katrina: How old is he?
Tasha: 12岁
Tasha: 12 years old.
Alice: 缺什么维生素还是什么
Alice: Is he lacking some vitamins or something?
Tasha: only 1米
Tasha: Only 1 meter tall.
Alice: 1米1米大概
Alice: About 1 meter, 1 meter.
Katrina:  基因突变了吗
Katrina: A genetic mutation?
Alice: 这
Alice: That...
Jake: 我有卷尺
Jake: I have a measuring tape.
Jake: 好哈哈
Jake: Okay, haha.
Tasha: 啊不用
Tasha: Ah, no need.
Katrina:  那确实有点啊
Katrina: Yeah, that's a bit unusual.
Katrina:  12岁就这么点高
Katrina: Only this tall at 12 years old.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Katrina:  当然好着急
Katrina: Of course, it's worrying.
Katrina:  男生女生啊
Katrina: Boy or girl?
Tasha: 男生
Tasha: A boy.
Alice: 他弟弟哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Her brother, hahaha!
Jake: 哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: Haha, that's brilliant.
Tasha: 我觉得可能是生他生的比较晚
Tasha: I think it might be because he was born late.
Katrina:  跟激素啊
Katrina: It could be hormones.
Katrina:  就是我有一个我爸爸同事就是他
Katrina: I know someone, my dad's colleague, he
Katrina:  他自己那叔叔就很矮
Katrina: His uncle is really short.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: So,
Katrina:  小时候就跟他儿子打那种什么促进骨
Katrina: When he was young, they gave his son those bone growth hormone shots.
Katrina:  骨骼发育的针
Katrina: It cost thousands each year.
Katrina:  反正一年还要大几千块钱
Katrina:  因为怕他儿子长不高
Katrina: Because they were worried he wouldn't grow tall.
Katrina:  因为那叔叔也就一米六
Katrina: His uncle is only 1.6 meters tall.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 好像说要先来测骨相
Tasha: Seems like we need to check bone structure first.
Katrina:  对要测什么骨龄啊
Katrina: Yeah, something about bone age.
Tasha: 看骨头还能不能再生长
Tasha: To see if the bones can still grow.
Katrina:  12岁应该还可以吧
Katrina: At 12, it should be fine, right?
Alice: 是不是还会测什么骨缝
Alice: Aren't they also checking bone gaps?
Alice: 什么闭合酶之类的
Alice: Something about closure enzymes or something.
Lucia: 对对要测
Lucia: Yes, exactly.
Katrina:  对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, right.
Lucia:  运动员也要测
Lucia: Athletes need to check that too.
Lucia:  那个
Lucia: And...
Lucia:  就是预测你接下来的身体发育情况
Lucia: It's to predict your future physical development.
Lucia: 小时候测过
Lucia: I had it checked when I was a kid.
Jake: 想当运动员
Jake: Wanted to be an athlete?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha!
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 不是不是
Lucia: Not at all.
Lucia: 我其实不想当运动员
Lucia: I actually didn't want to be an athlete.
Lucia: 只是那会机缘巧合
Lucia: It was just a coincidence at the time.
Jake: 可以当运动员
Jake: You could have been an athlete.
Jake: 但是不想当
Jake: But you didn't want to.
Tasha: 还记得小时候我们学哦
Tasha: 我上的班是什么国防班
Tasha: The class I attended was a national defense class.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 就是当兵当飞行员
Tasha: It was about becoming a soldier and a pilot.
Lucia: 哇好厉害呀
Lucia: Wow, that's amazing.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Tasha: 当时还有一批当飞行员的那个筛选
Tasha: At that time, there was a selection process for pilots.
Alice: 你弟弟的高度有大概吧
Alice: Your brother is about the right height, right?
Tasha: 嗯当时还有一批当
Tasha: Yeah, at that time there was still a batch of
Tasha: 飞行员的筛选结果
Tasha: results from the pilot selection.
Tasha: 前一天他体检前
Tasha: The day before his medical exam,
Tasha: 我不小心把他耳朵给划破了
Tasha: I accidentally scratched his ear.
Lucia: 错了哈哈
Lucia: Oh no, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哦
Jake: Haha, oh.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 飞不了了
Jake: He couldn't fly anymore.
Tasha: 我还在想完了他要是飞行员不通过
Tasha: I was thinking if he couldn't pass as a pilot,
Tasha: 会不会就人家要来找我麻烦
Tasha: would they come after me for causing trouble?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 就是飞行员身上不是不能有伤口吗
Tasha: Pilots can't have any wounds on their bodies, right?
Alice: 嗯对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 啊结果他成绩没有考过
Tasha: But in the end, he didn't pass the exam.
Tasha: 哈哈虚惊一场哈哈
Tasha: Haha, it was just a false alarm, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 虚惊一场
Jake: A false alarm.
Lucia: 虚惊一场
Lucia: A false alarm.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 呃这不是我的问题首先
Jake: 对对对撇清关系撇清责任
Jake: Yeah, yeah, clear the connection, clear the responsibility.
Alice: 飞行员还得看视力
Alice: Pilots also need good eyesight.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice: 就我们那个女女的宇航员刘洋嘛
Alice: Like our female astronaut Liu Yang.
Katrina:  嘘这太
Katrina: Shh, that's too...
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  这个核心力量太吓人了
Katrina: This core strength is too scary.
Alice: 他当时就是
Alice: At that time, she was...
Katrina:  什么时候能跳成这样啊
Katrina: When can I jump like that?
Alice: 他现在就是
Alice: Now, she...
Alice: 跟我弟那个学校
Alice: is at the same school as my brother.
Katrina:  这个是我开始玩的
Katrina: This is what I started playing.
Alice: 不对
Alice: No, that's wrong.
Katrina:  我OK我关注up主
Katrina: Okay, I'll follow the uploader.
Lucia: 他好厉害
Lucia: He's amazing.
Katrina:  我去这就力量型爵士
Katrina: Oh wow, this is power jazz.
Alice: 就是怎么说呢
Alice: How should I say this...
Alice: 就他曾经上的那个学校
Alice: The school he used to attend...
Katrina:  就这样一下我脖子咔嚓一声哈哈
Katrina: Just like that, my neck made a cracking sound, haha.
Alice: 那个那个那个那个那个宇航员
Alice: That astronaut...
Katrina:  嗯喜欢看一些大佬跳舞
Katrina: Yeah, I like watching some pros dance.
Alice: 他原来就是
Alice: He used to...
Alice: 上学的时候就是参加选拔吗
Alice: Participate in selections when he was in school.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice: 就好多人被筛掉就是因为视力不过关
Alice: Many people were eliminated because their vision didn't meet the standard.
Alice: 但是他当时视力就蛮好的
Alice: But his vision was pretty good at that time.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  太厉害了
Katrina: That's awesome.
Tasha: 但是当飞行员视力都要很好
Tasha: But to be a pilot, your vision has to be great.
Katrina:  娜娜记录
Katrina: Nanna, record this.
Tasha: 然后身上没有伤口
Tasha: And you can't have any scars on your body.
Alice: 嗯是的对
Alice: Yes, that's right.
Tasha: 然后好像还要转圈保持平衡
Tasha: And you have to spin around to maintain balance.
Katrina:  我我看一下
Katrina: Let me see.
Katrina:  你要跳舞吗或者是
Katrina: Do you want to dance or...
Tasha: 我也没有通过
Tasha: I didn't pass either.
Katrina:  然后跳舞嘛
Katrina: Then let's dance.
Jake: 宇航员
Jake: Astronaut.
Katrina:  跟那个偶像万万岁
Katrina: Along with that idol, Long Live.
Tasha: 对哦不好意思是飞行员我
Tasha: Oh right, sorry, I meant pilot.
Jake: 对宇航员
Jake: Yes, astronaut.
Alice: 宇航员
Alice: Astronaut.
Alice: 不好意
Alice: Sorry.
Katrina:  还有good time
Katrina: And good time.
Jake: 飞行员就要这样
Jake: Pilots have to do that.
Katrina:  呃就是这个
Katrina: Uh, it's this one.
Katrina:  还不如good time对吧
Katrina: Not as good as good time, right?
Katrina:  然后猪猪侠我们排掉了
Katrina: And we eliminated Piggy Hero.
Tasha: 要不跳
Tasha: How about dancing?
Katrina:  排除的排吗
Katrina: Eliminated, right?
Katrina:  排除了OK OK
Katrina: Eliminated, okay, okay.
Tasha: OK
Jake: 哈哈哈哎呀我去
Jake: Hahaha, oh my gosh
Tasha: 哈哈哈我就会一个动作
Tasha: Hahaha, I only know one move
Katrina:  哎我可以跳yes OK可以
Katrina: Oh, I can dance to "yes OK", no problem
Alice: 中有你是吗
Alice: Is it you in the middle?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈是吧
Tasha: Hahahaha, right?
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha
Katrina:  可以跳yes OK其实也
Katrina: I can dance to "yes OK" actually
Jake: 对很重要
Jake: Yes, very important
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake: 呵这是精华是吧
Jake: Haha, this is the essence, right?
Alice: 杨超越那个是啥呀
Alice: What's that Yang Chaoyue thing?
Katrina:  差不多跟我高中跳那个
Katrina: It's almost like what I did in high school
Tasha: 呃我不知道哎
Tasha: Uh, I don't know
Tasha: 创造101吗
Tasha: Is it "Produce 101"?
Alice: 青春有你是谁啊
Alice: Who's from "Youth with You"?
Katrina:  我那两个分不清哼
Katrina: I can't tell those two apart, ugh
Katrina:  那两个节目
Katrina: Those two shows
Alice: 有没有男团
Alice: Are there any boy bands?
Alice: 男团是啥
Alice: What's a boy band?
Katrina:  男团是那就是范丞丞他们出道
Katrina: A boy band is like where Fan Chengcheng debuted
Katrina:  那个是什么来着
Katrina: What was that called again?
Tasha: 什么也是什么
Tasha: What is it again?
Alice: 哎呦我的天
Alice: Oh my gosh
Tasha: 创造101吗
Tasha: Is it "Produce 101"?
Tasha: 我不清楚了
Tasha: I'm not sure
Alice: 时代少年团是谁啊
Alice: Who are "Times Youth League"?
Katrina:  少年团是直接公司出道的
Katrina: They directly debuted from a company
Katrina:  没有选秀那个
Katrina: No talent show involved
Katrina:  TF的那个家族
Katrina: They're from TF family
Tasha: 你要收回来吗
Tasha: Are you taking it back?
Jake: 没有我就玩
Jake: No, I'm just playing
Alice: 我刚一折
Alice: I just folded it
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha: 好你最多能挑出来多少米
Tasha: Okay, how much rice can you pick out at most?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Wow
Tasha: 我居然也想到了这个无聊的游戏
Tasha: I can't believe I also thought of this boring game
Jake: 他可能这个是这个
Jake: Maybe this is it
Jake: 这东西的上限跟人关系不大
Jake: The limit of this thing doesn't have much to do with people
Jake: 我感觉
Jake: I feel
Tasha: 我我其实刚刚想的就是挑战一下
Tasha: Actually, I was just thinking about challenging it
Tasha: 最高能折多少米
Tasha: How many meters can it fold at most
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Tasha: 好我们来猜一下最高还能折多少米
Tasha: Okay, let's guess how many meters it can fold at most
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Tasha: 谁能猜对
Tasha: Who can guess correctly
Jake: 呵呵呵把这全吃了
Jake: Haha, eat all of this
Tasha: 谁要是猜错了就把这些全吃了好吧
Tasha: Whoever guesses wrong will eat all of this, okay?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake: 那都全吃了
Jake: Then eat all of it
Tasha: 让我看一下现在多少米了
Tasha: Let me see how many meters it is now
Jake: 那你看啥呀
Jake: What are you looking at
Jake: 你要猜
Jake: You have to guess
Jake: 现在一米4243
Jake: Now it's 1.4243 meters
Tasha: 好你猜多少
Tasha: Okay, how much do you guess?
Jake: 我猜一米45
Jake: I guess 1.45 meters
Tasha: 就是就就会折掉
Tasha: That is, it will break
Tasha: 我们以那个为失败
Tasha: We'll take that as a failure
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 让我赌一米6
Tasha: Let me bet on 1.6 meters
Alice: 我觉得你要完了哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: I think you're done for, hahaha
Tasha: 啊啊那我要读一米五
Tasha: Ah, then I'll bet on 1.5 meters
Jake: 我也觉得你要完了啊
Jake: I also think you're done for
Alice: 呵呵
Alice: Hehe
Jake: 那也差不多完了
Jake: That's almost done for
Tasha: 你是一米多少
Tasha: How many meters did you guess?
Alice: 哈哈哈 1米45
Alice: Haha, 1.45 meters
Jake: 一米一米四五
Jake: 1.45 meters
Tasha: 那我就赌一米六
Tasha: Then I'll bet on 1.6 meters
Jake: 那你想吃你就
Jake: If you want to eat, you...
Alice: 没事反正哈哈
Alice: It's okay anyway, haha
Jake: 吃吧你要不
Jake: Go ahead and eat, if you...
Tasha: 那我赌一米555吧
Tasha: Then I'll bet on 1.555 meters
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 你要多少
Jake: How much do you want to bet?
Tasha: 1米55
Tasha: 1.55 meters
Jake: 一米55
Jake: 1.55 meters
Alice: 1米55跟一米45差10公哈哈
Alice: 1.55 meters and 1.45 meters, there's a 10 cm difference haha
Jake: 你你自己来你自己来一米55
Jake: You, you do it yourself, you try to be 1.55 meters
Tasha: 70年
Tasha: 70 years
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha
Alice: 因为它越长它这个
Alice: Because the longer it is, the...
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 哇哦
Jake: Wow
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice: 你悄悄作一下弊
Alice: You secretly cheat a bit
Alice: 你可以把你的手往前伸一点
Alice: You can stretch your hand forward a bit
Alice: 但也伸不了多远
Alice: But it won't go too far
Tasha: 哎好了啊可恶仔
Tasha: Okay, alright, you little rascal
Alice: 好了这才一米三多哈哈哈
Alice: Alright, it's only a bit over 1.3 meters haha
Jake: 挺强的
Jake: Pretty strong
Katrina:  这副歌跳了3遍
Katrina: This chorus was repeated 3 times
Katrina:  其实他新动作不是很多哎
Katrina: Actually, there aren't many new moves
Jake: 挺强挺强
Jake: Pretty strong, pretty strong
Alice: 没事
Alice: It's okay
Alice: 我给你
Alice: I'll give you
Alice: 感觉这玩意会割伤手
Alice: Feels like this thing might cut your hand
Jake: 嗯小心点
Jake: Yeah, be careful
Katrina:  其实难度不大
Katrina: Actually, it's not that difficult
Katrina:  我看了一下全是那个
Katrina: I checked, it's all that
Alice: 慢慢的
Alice: Slowly
Katrina:  然后奔跑青春你还要再看一下吗
Katrina: Then do you want to watch "Youth Run" again?
Alice: 有杠杆的感觉
Alice: It feels like there's a lever effect
Katrina:  奔跑青春跳出来蛮好看的
Katrina: "Youth Run" looks pretty good when dancing
Alice: 没关系没关系
Alice: It's okay, it's okay
Katrina:  但是感觉只能跳一分钟
Katrina: But it feels like you can only dance for a minute
Alice: 哎呀拉地了哈哈
Alice: Oh no, it pulled the ground haha
Tasha: 啊哈哈别
Tasha: Ah, no, stop
Jake: 哈哈哈来吃开吃
Jake: Hahaha, come on, let's eat
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 这是用什么
Jake: What's this made of?
Jake: 这是加了什么别的材料吗
Jake: Did you add some other ingredients?
Jake: 除了面面粉面粉面粉鸡蛋没了
Jake: Besides flour, flour, flour, eggs, nothing else?
Alice: 就糖
Alice: Just sugar
Tasha: 面粉鸡蛋
Tasha: Flour and eggs
Jake: 嗯可以
Jake: Hmm, okay
Jake: 这什么曲子
Jake: What's this song?
Jake: 我去小孩吗
Jake: Am I going to the kid?
Jake: 这都
Jake: This is all...
Katrina:  高中生
Katrina: High schoolers
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Alice: 我真没见过蘸白糖的吃法
Alice: I've never seen anyone dip it in white sugar
Jake: 真的吗对那确实可能只有那一片
Jake: Really? Yeah, maybe it's just in that area
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Alice: 嗯对
Alice: Yeah
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice: 但我们那有甜豆腐脑跟咸豆腐脑
Alice: But we have sweet tofu pudding and salty tofu pudding
Jake:是
Jake: Yes
Tasha: 那我们吃吃咸豆腐呢
Tasha: So, shall we try the salty tofu?
Jake: 啊已经不记得了
Jake: Ah, I don't remember anymore
Jake: 现在好像这什么店都能开
Jake: Nowadays, it seems like any kind of shop can open
Jake: 已经不知道以前是什么味儿
Jake: I don't even remember what the original taste was
Jake: 因为有很多外地的人吧
Jake: Because there are many people from other places
Jake: 所以什么味儿都有
Jake: So there are all kinds of flavors
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake: 这一分半
Jake: This is one and a half minutes
Katrina:  感觉跟那个跟3分的差不多
Katrina: Feels almost the same as three minutes
Katrina:  看下也是OK
Katrina: Looks okay too
Jake: 这后面什么字
Jake: What's written here?
Alice: 啥呀
Alice: What is it?
Jake: 这是一个团
Jake: It's a group
Jake: 哦好吧
Jake: Oh, okay
Tasha: 狗剩子不知道
Tasha: I don't know who Gou Sheng is
Alice: 谁是狗剩子
Alice: Who's Gou Sheng?
Jake: 我们后面也放一圈
Jake: We'll put a circle at the back too
Jake: 呵呵放一个什么呢
Jake: Haha, what should we put?
Lucia: 可以是自己设计一个logo哈哈
Lucia: We could design our own logo, haha
Jake: 哈哈可以
Jake: Haha, sounds good
Lucia: 因为每个练舞人就是就是那样
Lucia: Because every dancer has one like that
Tasha: 哈哈是吧
Tasha: Haha, right?
Lucia: 就会在后面放
Lucia: They always put it at the back
Tasha: 不记得了
Tasha: I don't remember
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Alice: 坐你旁边吧
Alice: I'll sit next to you.
Lucia: 然后每次上完课之后
Lucia: And every time after class,
Lucia: 就会有人拿那个酷炫的那个有有
Lucia: someone would bring that cool, you know,
Lucia: 说什么云台的相机
Lucia: what's it called, a gimbal camera.
Katrina:  可以跳yes okay了
Katrina: We can jump to "yes okay" now.
Lucia: 然后给你录往前往后
Lucia: and they'd record you moving back and forth.
Katrina:  哈哈其实可以跳yes okay
Katrina: Haha, actually, we can jump to "yes okay."
Jake: 哦OK OK
Jake: Oh, OK OK.
Lucia: 然后录出那种视频的效果
Lucia: and then create that video effect.
Tasha: 或者那个什么呃
Tasha: Or, um...
Katrina:  我要不发群里
Katrina: How about I post it in the group?
Katrina:  你们自己挑
Katrina: You guys pick.
Katrina:  说服一下那个修硕
Katrina: Convince Shure.
Tasha: 啊他也要跳啊
Tasha: Oh, he has to dance too?
Katrina:  哈哈不拉
Katrina: Haha, no.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  你来呗我最喜欢看男生跳女团舞了
Katrina: Come on, I love watching guys dance girl group dances.
Jake: 他可以跳
Jake: He can dance.
Jake: 我觉得可以
Jake: I think he can.
Katrina:  还可以我觉得
Katrina: I think he can too.
Alice: 我觉得跳起来没准比我们还
Alice: I think if he dances, he might even...
Katrina:  对比我们更妖娆的有可能
Katrina: Yeah, he might be even more graceful than us.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey.
Alice: 还还娇羞呢
Alice: And bashful too.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Alice: 哈哈娇俏哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha, adorable, hahaha.
Katrina:  这也不是很快吗
Katrina: Isn't this fast enough?
Tasha: afterlike afterlike
Tasha: Afterlike, afterlike.
Katrina:  Afterlife那是不是有点难
Katrina: Afterlife, isn't that a bit hard?
Tasha: 有点难吗
Tasha: Is it a bit hard?
Katrina:  嗯那是女团舞
Katrina: Hmm, it's a girl group dance.
Tasha: 我看好多男生在网上跳那个房舞
Tasha: I see a lot of guys dancing to it online.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 还有那个Dota
Tasha: And there's that Dota one.
Katrina:  低头吗还是什么
Katrina: Is it the bowing one or something?
Tasha: 哦低头
Tasha: Yeah, the bow.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  低头那有点难那个
Katrina: The bowing one is a bit hard.
Tasha: 那个有点难吗
Tasha: That one's a bit hard?
Tasha: 他那个节奏很简单吧
Tasha: His rhythm is quite simple, right?
Katrina:  他那个跳不出那个new爵士的感觉
Katrina: He can't break out of that new jazz vibe.
Katrina:  这还行是吧
Katrina: This is okay, right?
Katrina:  这多少 1分 43 还行
Katrina: What's this? 1 minute 43 seconds? It's okay.
Tasha: afterlike
Tasha: Afterlike
Katrina:  拿出来给我看看啊
Katrina: Take it out and show me.
Alice:是不是该换水了
Alice: Should we change the water?
Katrina:  呜呜呜哎
Katrina: Oh no, oh no.
Katrina:  昨天昨天新换的
Katrina: We changed it yesterday.
Katrina:  嗯afterlike好有意思
Katrina: Hmm, Afterlike is so interesting.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Katrina:  张元英的团
Katrina: Jang Wonyoung's group.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  这有点难
Katrina: This is kind of hard.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Tasha: 挑战张元英转圈舞那个
Tasha: Challenge Jang Wonyoung's spinning dance.
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake: 哈哈哈可以
Jake: Hahaha, sounds good.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Katrina:  是真爱豆啊
Katrina: She's a true idol.
Katrina:  看张元英的
Katrina: Look at Jang Wonyoung.
Lucia: 两天都经常跳
Lucia: She dances every day.
Lucia: 很有力量才
Lucia: With such strength.
Lucia: 能跳出它这个效果来
Lucia: She can achieve that effect.
Lucia: 我觉得我们这几天可能好不了
Lucia: I think we might not be able to do it in the next few days.
Katrina:  呜啊啊
Katrina: Ugh.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 哈这要跳给谁看呢最终
Tasha: Ha, who are we performing this for in the end?
Jake: 得从健身开始
Jake: We need to start with fitness.
Jake: 呃呃呃
Jake: Ugh, ugh, ugh.
Lucia: 嗯呃我们
Lucia: Hmm, we...
Katrina:  那也是OK吧
Katrina: That's okay too, right?
Jake: 相机哎
Jake: Camera, hey.
Lucia: 可我们还不是有什么九刀救无穷
Lucia: But we still have a long way to go.
Katrina:  虫子
Katrina: Bugs.
Jake: 呵呵呵对
Jake: Haha, right.
Lucia: 哈哈哈啊
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 九到正无穷
Jake: Nine to infinity.
Tasha: 啊这么可怕
Tasha: Ah, that's so scary.
Jake: 14亿全国人民
Jake: 1.4 billion people nationwide
Jake: 呵呵呵呵不
Jake: Hahaha, no
Alice: 能不能是全球人民
Alice: How about global people?
Jake: 七十亿全球人民
Jake: 7 billion people worldwide
Katrina:  人民
Katrina: People
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake: 七十亿全球人民呵
Jake: 7 billion people worldwide, haha
Katrina:  帮我拿下手机薇薇
Katrina: Tasha, can you get my phone?
Alice: 这个吗
Alice: This one?
Tasha: 看那个台舞吧
Tasha: Let's watch that stage dance
Alice: 塔莎你在吗
Alice: Tasha, are you there?
Tasha: yes you see you say
Tasha: Yes, you see, you say
Jake: 像这个领域大概有有100个组
Jake: In this field, there are probably around 100 groups
Jake: 100个组在做
Jake: 100 groups doing this
Jake: 如果他们都用你们的这个数据的话
Jake: If they all use your data
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What?
Jake: 就至少是100个研究员
Jake: That’s at least 100 researchers
Jake: 他们要看你们跳舞
Jake: They need to watch you dance
Jake: 对呵呵呵呵呵对
Jake: Yes, hahaha, yes
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 处理一下
Lucia: Handle it
Jake: 对对对但是是但是你们就会跳舞吗
Jake: Yes, yes, but can you dance?
Jake: 对没事
Jake: It's fine
Lucia: 没事他不知道是我就行
Lucia: It's okay, he won't know it's me
Jake: 是是没问题
Jake: Yes, yes, no problem
Lucia: 没事你听不着说就行
Lucia: It's fine, just don’t let him hear
Lucia: 不知道是我就是
Lucia: As long as he doesn't know it's me
Lucia: 其实我拍的也无所谓
Lucia: It doesn't matter if I shoot it
Lucia: 就算就算跳砸了他也不知道是咋回事
Lucia: Even if the dance is messed up, he won’t know what's going on
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: It's over
Katrina:  lady Candle呀
Katrina: Lady Candle, huh
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Alice: 简直不敢相信我要是跳这个舞
Alice: I can't believe if I dance this
Alice: 会有多扭曲
Alice: How twisted it would be
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god
Alice: 哈哈哈疯了吧
Alice: Hahaha, you must be crazy
Tasha: 疯了吧
Tasha: Are you crazy?
Katrina: 张元英他们团队舞你看着简单
Katrina: Zhang Yuanying's team dance looks simple
Katrina: 好像没什么用力
Katrina: Seems like they don't use much force
Katrina: 但是你跳出来很丑
Katrina: But if you try, it looks ugly
Katrina: 你跳不出来那种感觉好
Katrina: You can't get the right feeling
Katrina: 就他们团队舞
Katrina: Their team dance
Katrina: 我就我经常不知道怎么发力
Katrina: I often don't know how to use my strength
Tasha: 那yes OK
Tasha: Well, yes, OK
Tasha: 确实很简单啊
Tasha: It is really simple
Katrina: 我分享到群里面
Katrina: I'll share it in the group
Katrina: 哎他鼓点还挺强的
Katrina: Hey, the beat is pretty strong
Alice: 来我家玩吧
Alice: Come over to my place
Alice: 邀请你
Alice: I'm inviting you
Tasha: 看能不能抢到医院的票
Tasha: See if we can get tickets for the hospital
Tasha: 我可能五一就要跟我妈妈在北京看病
Tasha: I might have to go to Beijing with my mom for a check-up on May Day
Tasha: life
Tasha: Life
Alice: life
Alice: Life
Katrina:  我发大群里吧
Katrina: I'll share it in the big group
Lucia: 剧组会不会跟我们一起跳
Lucia: Will the crew dance with us?
Jake: 可以跳可以跳
Jake: They can dance, they can dance
Alice: 剧组是不是就最后一天会来
Alice: The crew will only come on the last day, right?
Jake: 呃也不是周五吧
Jake: Uh, it's not Friday, right?
Jake: 周五他们上课啊
Jake: They have classes on Friday
Alice: 今天周几周三
Alice: What day is today? Wednesday?
Jake: 今天就会来两个
Jake: Only two will come today
Jake: 上课打卡
Jake: Class check-in
Jake: 呃就是紫藤唯一的女生她要打卡
Jake: Uh, the only girl in Zitong, she needs to check-in
Jake: 他们实验室要打卡
Jake: Their lab needs to check-in
Jake: 所以不太方便来
Jake: So it's inconvenient to come
Jake: 周末可以来
Jake: They can come on the weekend
Jake: 周五周六周日
Jake: Friday, Saturday, Sunday
Katrina:  奔跑的青春要分享吗
Katrina: Should we share "Running Youth"?
Lucia: 要不分享一下让大家看一看
Lucia: How about sharing it for everyone to see?
Lucia: 然后觉得不过不好
Lucia: If they don't think it's good
Lucia: 像现在这几个里面
Lucia: Among the current ones
Lucia: 应该属于比较难的一个
Lucia: This is probably one of the hardest
Jake: 放到管家群
Jake: Post it in the butler group
Jake: 管家一起跳就给你们开小车的
Jake: The butlers will dance and give you a ride
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: That's fine.
Lucia: 欢迎
Lucia: Welcome.
Jake: 你们都做过了吗
Jake: Have you all done it?
Jake: 都做过了
Jake: All done?
Alice: 我没
Alice: I haven't.
Jake: 你还没有做哦
Jake: You haven't done it yet?
Jake: 今天给你
Jake: I'll give you one today.
Jake: 今天还有一次
Jake: There's another chance today.
Alice: 但我没快递
Alice: But I don't have a delivery.
Jake: 没关系今天该兜风了嘛
Jake: It's okay, today we can go for a ride.
Katrina:  该买嗯
Katrina: Should buy, yeah.
Lucia: 我们如果要买东西的话
Lucia: If we want to buy something...
Jake: 对是的
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Katrina:  OK这4个挑吧
Katrina: Okay, choose from these four.
Lucia: P人的快乐时刻就是让他用帮忙决定的
Lucia: The happiest moment for P is to let him help decide.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Katrina:  投票吧
Katrina: Let's vote.
Lucia: 而且因为我这几年就是我我
Lucia: And because in the past few years, I...
Lucia: 我前两年就开始
Lucia: I started a couple of years ago...
Jake: 哦对就是这个
Jake: Oh right, it's this one.
Lucia: 这个是我们
Lucia: This is ours...
Jake: 这个没有办法一起挑
Jake: This one can't be chosen together.
Katrina:  什么风格
Katrina: What style?
Jake: 对嗯
Jake: Yes, mm-hmm.
Katrina:  给我看看
Katrina: Show me.
Lucia: 这个是前前年的一个
Lucia: This is from the year before last.
Katrina:  啊我就说你有这方
Katrina: Ah, I knew you had this style.
Katrina:  感觉你很有这个气质
Katrina: You really have this vibe.
Lucia: 然后我之前学了一段时间Hi-Pop
Lucia: And I learned Hi-Pop for a while before.
Lucia: 但这几年都没怎么跳了
Lucia: But I haven't danced much these years.
Katrina:  有点偏民族
Katrina: It's a bit ethnic.
Lucia: 对对可能更现代舞一点
Lucia: Yeah, maybe more like modern dance.
Lucia: 因为我是没做过民族这个课
Lucia: Because I didn't take any ethnic dance classes.
Lucia: 我们当时是教现代舞
Lucia: We were taught modern dance at the time.
Lucia: 然后所以就我直接躺下去
Lucia: So I just lay down.
Lucia: 就是老师说你们要用到快点学了之后
Lucia: The teacher said we had to learn quickly after that.
Katrina:  嗯嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Lucia: 然后我就躺下
Lucia: So I just lay down.
Katrina:  你这好有气质
Katrina: You have such a vibe.
Katrina:  这个这个
Katrina: This, this...
Katrina:  我有点跳不来
Katrina: I kind of can't jump.
Katrina:  因为我感觉我没那么柔
Katrina: Because I feel like I'm not that flexible.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This...
Lucia: 而且这个也不适合咱们这个场地
Lucia: And this isn't suitable for our venue either.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  我们学校办金秋舞蹈时候
Katrina: When our school hosted the Golden Autumn Dance...
Katrina:  就全部都跳这种舞
Katrina: ...everyone danced this kind of dance.
Alice: 可以坐我旁边吗
Alice: Can you sit next to me?
Katrina:  跳那种讲历史的那种舞
Katrina: ...they danced those historical dances.
Alice: 喜欢跟你在一块
Alice: I like being with you.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈可以可以
Jake: Hahaha, sure, sure.
Lucia: 这个我忘编的
Lucia: I forgot to choreograph this part.
Lucia: 我们老师让每个每个同学定
Lucia: Our teacher made every student decide.
Katrina:  你哦你自己编的
Katrina: Oh, you choreographed it yourself?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 我们老师让每个同学自己选一个音乐
Lucia: Our teacher let each student choose a piece of music.
Lucia: 然后编一段
Lucia: And then choreograph a part.
Lucia: 然后但其实我只编了前一分半
Lucia: But actually, I only choreographed the first minute and a half.
Lucia: 随后一份半我就胡乱无吐哈哈
Lucia: For the next minute and a half, I just made it up on the spot, haha.
Alice: 后一分半我知道
Alice: I know about the second half.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  心理素质好强啊
Katrina: You've got strong nerves.
Katrina:  居然能当人的面糊了
Katrina: You actually winged it in front of people.
Lucia: 哈就有点有点推荐卡拉OK那个意思
Lucia: It's kind of like recommending karaoke, haha.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 后面我就开始随意发挥
Lucia: After that, I just started improvising.
Lucia: 把前面的东西再抄一遍
Lucia: And repeated the earlier stuff again.
Jake: 可以freestyle
Jake: You can freestyle.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 不然没有人知道他原本是什么样的
Lucia: Otherwise, no one would know what it was originally like.
Katrina:  看一下如果这个只有1分多
Katrina: Look, if this is only a minute long...
Alice: 这个舞我来跳
Alice: I'll dance this.
Alice: 不知道有多丑陋哈哈哈
Alice: I don't know how ugly it will be, haha.
Lucia: 因为疫情的时候就是回国
Lucia: Because when the pandemic happened, I went back to my country.
Lucia: 然后不是有一段时间就刚好
Lucia: And for a while, it was just...
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 马上就是就要结束了
Lucia: It was about to end.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 但是就是还没有
Lucia: But it still wasn't over.
Lucia: 那个当时
Lucia: At that time
Lucia: 还没有就是
Lucia: It hadn't yet...